The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
OK, so I thought
I'd quickly list the four
central topics for the Fourier
part of the course,
and I would guess
that there'll be a question
on each of those four
in the final quiz.
Final exam.
And we covered 4.1,
Fourier series.
I don't plan to do discussion
in 4.2 of other series
like Bessel and
Legendre and so on.
If I can, I'll
come back to those
in the very last lectures.
But I want to pick up now on
the second key example, which
is the discrete Fourier series
that has only N terms, instead
of this series, as
you're looking at it,
has infinitely many terms.
But I'm going to
cut back to N terms.
So this k, well I
can go one to N,
but the best way is zero to N-1.
So that's the discrete series.
We're going to be dealing with
a vector, c_0 up to c_(N-1).
And a vector of function values.
Vector to vector.
So a matrix is going to be
the key to everything here.
An N by N matrix.
So that's what's coming.
Then, after that
probably by Friday
will be the integral transform.
And early next week, and a
little after Thanksgiving,
would be this key
idea of convolution,
which is really important
in so many applications
and needs to be separated out.
Convolution will
apply to all of these.
And you'll see the point there.
OK, ready for the idea
of the discrete one.
OK, so the key idea is we only
have N terms, so I can't expect
to reproduce a whole function.
I can get N function
values, so I'll
get this at N different points.
And if I'm thinking
of my F(x), on,
let me take zero to 2pi
now, and I'm thinking again
of an F(x) that's periodic.
So it goes, does whatever.
If it was like that,
if that was my F(x),
just remember about
Fourier series,
what could you tell me about the
Fourier series for that F(x)?
Well, when I continue
periodically,
am I going to see a jump?
Yes.
There'll be a jump at every
2pi, so the underlying function
is not continuous, has a jump,
so that our special examples
with jumps and slow decay,
1/k decay rate for the Fourier
coefficients would apply here.
OK, that's remembering
Fourier series.
Now, Fourier integrals,
I'm just going to take,
let me just take N=4.
So I'll take this point, you
know, what four points am I
going to take?
I'm not going to repeat-- Ah.
Just for the heck of it,
let's make it look periodic.
Yeah, let's make
it look periodic.
I never should have
done it otherwise.
OK, so there's one point.
I'm just going to take four
equally spaced, equally spaced
being key, zero,
one, two, three.
So N-1 is three.
And these four values
I can get right.
So those are my four x's.
The four x's that
I'm going to take.
So this is x=0, of course.
And this one is,
what's the x there?
x is 2pi, the whole deal,
the whole interval, but it's
divided into N pieces,
so 2pi/N. So we
are going to see a lot of
fractions involving pi/N.
Or 2pi/N. They're just
going to come up everywhere.
Because that's the
delta x, the h,
the step in the discrete form.
OK.
So those are the x's.
So I'm only going to get
this at x=0, 2pi/N, 4pi/N,
up to whatever it comes
out to, (N-1)*2pi/N.
That doesn't look elegant so
we probably will try to avoid
writing that again.
But this was the three times
2pi/4 that got us to there.
So this is 2pi/8, pi/4.
Sorry, 2pi/4,
4pi/4, 6pi-- Oh, OK.
So we're only going to
get equality at those x's.
So it's those x's that
I should plug in here.
OK, so let me do that.
Let me plug in, what
does this series look
like at these four points?
Let me see.
So writing out all
four equations,
F(0) is going to match the
right side at zero, because zero
is one of my points.
So I get c_0 + c_1 + c_2 + c_3.
At x=0, right, all the e
to the whatevers were one.
Now at the next
x, 2pi/N, now I'm
matching the series with a
function at that value, there.
2pi/N. So now I have k=0,
so what does k=0 give me?
When k is zero, what's
my term look like?
It's just c_0 times one.
Because if k is zero, e to
the whatever is again one.
So this is just c_0.
Now, here's the key.
What is that business
there at x=2pi/N?
Here comes the important
number in this whole business.
The important number this whole
business is, I'll call it w,
is e^(2pi*i/N).
That's a complex
number, and we'll
place it in the complex plane.
So you must get to
know that number, w.
Because when I
plug in x equal-- k
is now one here, so I have c_1.
Times this e to the i one
2pi/N, what is that? w.
So it's w*c_1.
And what do I get from the
next term in this series?
I have c_2*e^(i2x).
x is 2pi/N, do you
see what's happening?
w squared is e^(4pi*i/N).
We're using the beauty
of exponentials,
that's making everything go.
It's w squared.
And this guy would
be w cubed, c_3.
That's the series.
At our points.
So this, like, we'll just see
this once, what are we doing?
But this is what we're
going to live with here.
So I'll rewrite it
all in terms of w,
so you just, you've got the
idea of what are we doing?
We're matching at N points and
now we get the good notation w.
OK, and at the next point,
4pi/N. Well, again, k=0 term,
it's c_0.
The k=1 term, can you tell
me what I get when k is one,
I have something times c_1,
it's e^(i*1*4pi/N), what's that?
w squared. e^(i*4pi/N)
is w squared.
Look, this matrix is
coming out symmetric.
And this will be w^4, and
that'll turn out to be w^6,
and then the last row of the
matrix is going to come from
matching at 6pi/N, and it
will turn out to be c_0,
and it'll be w^3, w^6, and w^9.
So I did the last row
or two a bit fast.
Just because the pattern's
there, and you'll spot it.
Now I want to pull out
of that the matrix.
The Fourier matrix, the four
by four Fourier matrix that
multiplies the c's
and gives me the f's.
Let me call these numbers are
y_0, y_1, y_2, and y_3, just
to have a, so it's a vector
of values of the function.
And this is a vector
of coefficients.
So it's wise to-- The Fourier
transform goes between
y's and c's, and y's.
Connects a vector--
And this is N values,
N function values
in physical space.
These are N coefficients
in frequency space,
and one way is the
discrete Fourier transform
and the other way is the inverse
discrete Fourier transform.
So, and it's a little bit
confused, which is which,
actually.
There was no question
with Fourier series,
it was easy to tell the
function from the coefficients
because the function was
f(x) and the coefficients
were a bunch of numbers.
Here we only have N numbers.
N y's and N c's and we're
transforming back and forth.
So I'm finding right
now the matrix,
this Fourier matrix is going
to take the c's and give me
the y's.
So I'm talking here
about the matrix F.
And let's see what F is.
Can you just see what--
That was y_0 to y_3,
equals this matrix F,
the four by four matrix.
Times c_0 to c_3.
This is really the inverse DFT.
It reconstructs the y's from
the c's, or an easier way
to say that is
add up the series.
So that's the-- The
usual DFT is taking us,
starting with the y's
and giving us the c's.
So this would be the
discrete Fourier transform.
Take a function, produce
its coefficients.
The reverse step is
take the coefficients,
add back, add up the
series, get the function.
And that's what F does.
So I'm going to focus on
F. Which is the ones that
involves this w guy.
OK, can you read off,
peel off from here
what the matrix F is,
the Fourier matrix?
Its first row is all ones.
Its first column is all ones.
And then it's one, w, w^2,
w^3; w^2, w^4, w^6; w^3, w^6,
and w^9.
To the ninth power.
OK, so it's made up
of these powers of w.
Zero, first, second, and third
power and then higher powers.
But higher powers are
all-- Let's draw a picture.
Where is w?
So this is the complex plane.
Here's the real, and here's
the imaginary direction.
And let me take N to
be, here N was four.
Let me take N to be eight in
my picture, just to have some,
then I'll be able to spot
the fours and the eights.
If N is eight,
where would w_8 be?
So w_8 is meant to be
the e^(2pi*i/8), now.
Where's that number
in that picture?
Is it on the circle?
Absolutely.
This discrete Fourier transform
never gets off the circle.
And in fact, it never gets off
eight points on the circle.
Which are the eight
equally spaced points.
This says go 1/8 of the way
of the whole way around,
which will be here.
So there's w_8.
When I square it, what's
the square of w_8?
The angle, what happens to the
angle when I multiply numbers?
I add the exponents.
Here, if I'm
multiplying by itself,
it'll double the exponent.
Double the angle.
It'll be, there's w_8 squared,
so that point is w_8 squared.
And it's the same as w_4 because
it's 1/4 of the way around.
And what is that number
in ordinary language? i.
It's i, right?
It's on the unit
circle at 90 degrees.
And on the imaginary
axis it's just i.
So all this here was i, i^2 i^3;
i^2, i^4, i^6; i^3, i^6, i^9.
The four by four Fourier
matrix is just powers of i.
And the N by N, the eight
by eight Fourier matrix
is powers of w_8.
And let's find all the
rest of the powers.
So there's w_8, w_8
squared, where's w_8 cubed?
Here.
I multiply those guys, I add
the angle, I'm out to here.
Here's the fourth power, here's
the fifth power, sixth power,
seventh power and
finally we get to w_8
to the eighth
power, which is one.
Because if I take the eighth
power here, I've got e^(2pi*i),
and that's one.
So that's the
picture to remember.
And while looking
at that picture,
could you tell me the sum
of those eight numbers?
What do those eight
members add up to?
So I just want to ask what
do one plus w up to w^7,
when I'm doing the
eighth guy, adds up to?
So the sum of those
eight numbers,
well I wouldn't ask
the question if it
didn't have a nice answer.
Zero.
That's of course the
usual answer in math.
We do all this work
and we get zero.
But now, of course
the real math is why.
I mean, so math is,
you get equations
but then always there's
that kicker, why.
And why do they add up to zero?
Here.
Can you see that?
Why those eight numbers
would add to zero?
Well, yeah.
So what do these add up to?
Just those two guys?
One and minus one add to zero.
That and that add to
zero, I can pair them off.
This and this add to zero.
That and that add to zero.
Yeah, so that's one
way of seeing it.
But actually, even if N was
three or five or some odd
number, and I had-- So should
I do the picture for N=3?
Just a little, doesn't need
a very big picture for N=3.
So where would the
roots be for N=3?
One of them is always one.
These are the three
cube roots of one.
That I'm going to draw.
Those were the eight
eighth roots of one.
Because if I take any
one of those numbers
its eighth power
brings me back to one.
So where are these guys, so
this is three numbers equally
spaced around the circle.
Where do you think they are?
Well, it's gotta be at 120
degrees, 240 degrees and 360.
And again, those
will add to zero.
You can't pair them off
because we got an odd number,
but it's safely zero
and we could see why.
OK, so this section, this
topic is all about that matrix.
It's all about that four
by four, or N by N matrix.
Which has powers of w.
Notice that the matrix is,
it hasn't got any zeroes.
Hasn't even got
anything close to zero.
All those numbers are
on the unit circle.
So multiplying by
that matrix, which
is the same as adding up the
Fourier series at the four
points, doing this
calculation, finding these y's
from the c's, reconstructing
the y's, given the coefficients,
has 16 terms.
Right?
The matrix has got 16 entries,
all the entries in the matrix
are showing up here
in powers of w.
We've got 16 multiplications.
Well, maybe a couple of them
were easy, but basically 16
multiplications and additions.
Pretty much N squared work.
And that's not bad.
Except if you want to do
it a million times, right?
Suppose we have a
typical N might be 1024.
So the matrix has then got,
is 1024 squared numbers,
which is about a million.
So if we have a matrix
with a million entries,
a million operations to do, and
then we do it a million times
then it's getting up
to money that Congress
would give to the banks.
Whatever.
Anyway.
Serious money.
Serious computing time.
And the wonderful
thing is that there
is a faster way than N squared.
There's a faster way to do these
16 terms than the obvious way.
You might say, well,
they're pretty nice.
And they are.
But they're nicer
than you can know.
I mean, nicer than you
can see immediately.
This matrix will break
up into simple steps
with lots of zeroes
in each step,
and the final result is
that instead of n squared,
capital N squared, which is
done the old fashioned way,
let's say, that there's
a fast Fourier transform.
So the FFT, I should
maybe find a better space
for the most important algorithm
in the last hundred years,
and here it is.
Right there.
So my one goal
for Wednesday will
be to give you some
insight into the FFT.
But here I'm just
looking at the result.
The number of computations
is, instead of N squared,
it's N times log N. It's
log to the base two,
or maybe 1/2 N log N. So I'll
erase some of the other things
close by so you can see it.
So that, where N squared
was, if N was a thousand,
N squared was a million.
If N is a thousand,
this is a thousand,
and what's the logarithm of
a thousand, to the base two?
That's the ten, right?
The 2^10 gave us that 1,024.
So this is 10^4.
So N is 10^3, or 1,024 more
exactly, the logarithm is ten,
so we're 10^4 instead of 10^6.
So that's a saving of a
factor of 100, that's true.
I mean it just comes from doing
the addition and multiplication
in the right order.
You get this incredible saving.
And it's sort of makes
whole calculations that
were previously
impossible are now
possible because instead of
where it might have been 100
minutes, it's now one minute.
So everything focuses on this
Fourier matrix and its inverse,
which we still have to find
but it'll come out beautifully.
In fact, I could tell
you what F inverse,
just so you see it coming.
F inverse will, so
what happened to w,
that all-important number w?
Well, let me repeat what w is.
I'll put it on this board.
F has powers of w.
w is e^(2pi*i/N).
And what power has it got?
In the j,k position?
So now you can see the
formula for these entries.
Only, you have to let me
start the count at j and k
equals zero.
This is zero-based, where
MATLAB is one-based.
And to do this stuff you always
have to shift things by one.
Some other, more recent,
software like Python
is zero based, because
this is so common.
So here's the formula.
It's w to the power j times k.
That's neat.
That's what goes into the matrix
F. This here is row three.
It looks like row four but
I'm starting with zero,
so that's row three.
That's column three.
This is w three
times three, w^9.
Which by the way is
the same as what?
If w is i in this four by four,
it is. w is i, what's w^9,
what's i to the 9th power?
Same as?
Can you do i^9 in your head?
Sure.
Because you're starting here.
You're taking its ninth power,
so one, two, three, four,
you're back to one. i^4 is one.
One, two, three, four
more, i^8 is one. i^9.
That will actually
be just i. i^9.
So they're all powers of i.
But this is the
good way to see it.
It's three times three, because
it's in-- And this, of course,
is three times two, and two
times two, and three times one.
You see the entries of F?
Yeah.
So now I'd better
write down, I promised
to write this formula
in a better form.
All those formulas
in a better-- Nobody
is going to write this out for
matrices of order 1000, right?
So we've got to write
the decent formula.
So the decent formula
is that the j-th y,
because it's going to
come in equation number j,
will be the sum on k=0 to
N-1, of c_k times w^(jk).
Those are the entries, those
are the c's that it multiplies
and the y's.
This is just y, vector
y, this is y=Fc.
Now we've finally
got a good notation.
So this was horrible notation.
I mean, that's exhausting.
This shows you the
algebra, but you
have to be sort of prepared--
Well, the information is here
because this is telling
you what the entries of F,
of the matrix, are.
But this is with indices, and
this is with whole vectors.
So that would be
y, in MATLAB that
would be the inverse fast
Fourier transform of c.
So you see that
that's our matrix.
Now, I was going
to say, before I
show why, I was going to
say what about the inverse?
Because if the FFT gave us
a fast way to multiply by F,
we want it also to give us a
fast way to do the inverse.
We have to go both ways here.
We get our data, we put
it into frequency space,
we look at it in
frequency space,
we understand what's going on.
By separating out
the frequencies.
We maybe smooth it, we maybe
convolve it, whatever we do.
Compress it.
And then we've got to go
back to physical space.
So we have to go both ways.
And the question is
what about F inverse?
And let me just say,
what goes into F inverse?
The point is that the number
that goes into F inverse
is just like w.
But it's the complex conjugate,
and I'll call it w bar.
And that's e^(-2pi*i/N).
So the thing that's going to
go into the inverse matrix
is the powers of w bar.
The complex conjugate. jk.
Let me just say right away,
that just as there were 2pi's
in the Fourier series
world, that got in our way.
And physicists can't
stand those 2pi's.
They try to get rid of them
but course they can't, they're
there.
So they put it up
into the exponent.
Well, I guess, I'm blaming
physicists, I've done it too.
I've put the 2pi up there.
For the Fourier series.
Anyway whatever, 2pi's
are all in your hair
in the Fourier series.
And in this, for
the discrete one,
the corresponding thing
is an N. There's a factor
N that I have to deal with.
Because look, here's
what I'm saying.
Let me multiply F by F inverse.
OK.
Say, 1, 1, 1, 1; 1 i, i^2,
i^3, this is my F, right?
Whoops.
Don't ever let me do that. i^2,
fourth, sixth; i^3, i^6, i^9.
Now, my claim is
that F inverse is
going to involve the complex
conjugate, w bar. i bar.
What is the complex
conjugate of i?
You see that we really have
to use complex numbers here,
but they're on the unit circle.
You couldn't ask
for a better line.
What's the complex
conjugate that's
going to go into F inverse?
If I take i and I take its
conjugate, what does that mean?
So the conjugate of
that is just, flip it
across the real axis
to the other one.
You see, it's great?
The complex conjugate
of i is minus i.
Here's w_8 here's w bar 8.
It's just across the axis.
So it still has size one.
And, of course, it's e to the?
This angle, which is
just minus this angle.
So that's why we get this minus.
Because when I flip it
across, i changes to minus i,
angle changes to minus angle.
And finally I was going to
do this multiplication just
to see.
So now I'm claiming that this is
1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1; -i, -i^2,
-i^3.
So on, -i^2, -i^3, fourth,
sixth, sixth, and ninth.
And now, if you do
that multiplication,
you will get the
identity matrix.
That's the great thing.
You get the identity.
1, 1, 1, 1.
Except for a factor N. And
do you see that coming?
When I multiply this
by this, what do I get?
Four.
If they were N by N, I'd
have N ones against N ones,
so I'd have to
expect an N there.
So F times F inverse,
so, in other words
if I want to get the identity,
I'd better divide this by N.
So now I have F F inverse
equal I. So F inverse is just
like F, except complex
conjugate and divide by N.
So if I want this formula
to be really correct,
I have to divide by N. OK?
So and that's what
w and w bar is.
And another letter that
often gets used in this topic
is omega.
And I figure that's a
good way to separate out
the complex conjugates,
let's call this guy w
and call this guy omega.
So this is w and here's omega.
I don't know if that helps.
But you do have to keep
straight whether you're
talking about this
number or that number.
And this number
could be called w,
because omega wouldn't
be easy to type.
So you have to pay attention,
which one you're doing
and when, somewhere you
have to divide by N.
But otherwise it's fantastic.
It's just beautiful.
Can we do that
multiplication, just
to see that it really works?
Well, the ones worked fine.
What about the ones times,
or what about the ones
times that column.
So I'm looking at the (1,2)
entry in this multiplication.
Or rather, the (0,1),
entry I should say.
This is the zeroth row, and
this is the row number one,
and what do I get out of that?
Zero, right.
That was my point.
That this is adding up, oh well,
going the other way around.
Because it's the
complex conjugate,
but it's adding up the four,
same four numbers and giving me
that zero.
And now how about the
ones on the diagonal?
When I do this times
this, so this is the same,
the row times itself.
What am I seeing there?
What are these terms?
That's certainly
one, what is i times
minus i? i times
minus i is one again.
A number's getting
multiplied by its conjugate.
That gives you something
real and positive
when you multiply a
number by its conjugate.
In fact, we get one every
time, so we get four ones,
we divide by four
and we get that.
Maybe you actually see
here, just so you remember.
So F inverse is, I'm concluding
that-- F inverse, I'm
looking now, what is F inverse?
It's F conjugate divided
by this nuisance number
N. I could put square
root of N with F,
and then square root of N
would show up with F inverse,
just the way I could have done,
square root of 2pi with one,
and square root of
2pi with the other.
But let's leave it like so.
So that's not proved in a way.
Just, checked for a
couple of cases with N=4,
but it always works.
That's the beauty.
In other words,
the two directions,
the y to c and the
c to y, are both
going to be speeded
up by the FFT.
The FFT, whatever
it did, whatever
it could do with the
w and powers of w,
it can do the same with w bar.
And powers of w bar.
If the FFT is a fast way
to to multiply by that,
it'll also give me a
fast way to multiply,
to do the other transform.
So the FFT is what makes every--
This would all be important
if the FFT didn't exist.
And of course actually,
Fourier didn't notice it.
Gauss again had the
idea, but he had
so many ideas it wasn't
very clear in his notes.
The FFT idea.
But then Cooley and Tukey,
guys at Bell Labs in the 1950s
discovered it.
In a small paper, I don't
think they had any idea
how important it would be.
But they published
their paper and people
saw what was happening, and
realized that they should,
that that gave the right
way to do the transforms.
OK, I was going to say here, do
you notice that this one, when
I take a vector, that
vectors and its complex
conjugate, what am I getting?
I'm getting the length squared.
I'm getting the
right inner product.
This is the right inner product
when things are complex.
Something times its conjugate.
I'm just reminding you that the
inner product of two vectors,
uv, u dot v or u comma v,
should now be the sum--
It used to be the
sum of u_i*v_i.
But now we're in
the complex case,
so we should take the
conjugate one of them.
And here I guess that's
the v, and this is the u,
and so the point is that
we're taking the right, yeah.
We have, oh yeah. let
me just say it this way.
These columns are orthogonal.
Those four columns, the
columns of the Fourier matrix,
are orthogonal.
In other words, we have
an orthogonal basis.
And it's those four columns.
I almost missed saying that.
But you remember from last week,
the whole point about sines
and cosines and exponentials
in the function case,
was orthogonal.
That's what made
everything work,
and it makes
everything work here.
Here we have vectors,
not functions.
Orthogonal just means
dot products are zero.
But they're complex, so
that in the dot product,
one factor or the other
has to get conjugated.
Anyway, that's an
orthogonal matrix.
Apart from this N,
this capital N thing.
So if I normalize it, if I take
out one over square root of N,
now the length of
every column is one.
So now I have
orthonormal columns.
One squared, one squared, one
squared, one squared is four,
divided by four is one.
And every column has
length, is a vector
in four-dimensional complex
space, of length one.
And orthogonal.
So that means orthonormal.
It's a fantastic matrix.
That's the best
basis we'll ever have
for complex
four-dimensional space.
That basis.
Well, actually when I say the
best basis we'll ever have,
I realize I wrote a
book about wavelets.
And the idea of wavelets
is, there's another basis.
A wavelet basis.
And I hope to tell
you about that
at the very end of the semester.
So wavelets would
be another basis,
would you like to know
the wavelet basis?
Have we got?
Just in case the end of
the semester doesn't come,
can I write down here
the wavelet basis?
OK.
And you can decide you
maybe like it better.
So the four by four
wavelet basis, alright.
So this will be
the wavelet matrix.
Well, this was too
good to lose, right?
That's a terrific vector.
All ones, constant vector.
It's the thing that
gives us the average,
this c_0 is going to again
be the average of the y's.
How do I get that average?
Somehow I'm doing, the
c_0, the constant term
is again I'm going to
take one of everything
and I'll divide by four
and I'll have the average.
So I like that vector.
That's the DC vector,
if I'm talking
about-- direct current vector,
if I'm talking about networks.
In an image, it
would be the whole,
you could call it the
blackboard vector.
The whole image of a empty
blackboard would be constant.
OK, so that's too good to lose.
Now, the obvious thing
orthogonal to that
would be [1, 1, -1, -1].
Right?
Now I've got two
orthogonal columns.
And probably that's pretty close
to something I have over here.
Now, here's the
point about wavelets.
You'll see it with the next guy.
The next one, you saw that
those two are orthogonal.
And real, and
simple, nice numbers.
Now, the next one will
be [1,  -1, 0, 0].
Do you see that
that's orthogonal?
Obviously, because its dot
product with that is zero
and that is zero.
And you want to tell me the
last column of the wavelet,
of the simple wavelet matrix?
This would be the Haar, named
after Haar, the Haar wavelets.
The whole point about
wavelets was a new basis.
Somebody realized,
well actually, Haar
lived a long time ago, but
they got improved and improved,
but here's the simplest one.
What's the good fourth column?
Fourth orthogonal vector here?
What shall I start with?
Zeroes, and then I'll
put one, minus one.
So the beauty of wavelets is,
I've got this averaging vector.
And then I've got this
difference, sort of
on a big scale, and then
I've got differences
on a little scale with zero,
differences here with zeroes
so as I keep going I could
do eight by eight, 16 by 16,
it would-- I get
the averaging guy.
And then I get differencing,
I get large scale differences
and then I get
finer differences.
So coarse differences,
finer differences,
finer finer differences.
And that's a really good
way to-- If your function,
if your signal has jumps, we
saw that Fourier wasn't perfect,
right?
And a lot of signals have jumps.
Right?
Your shocks, whatever
you're trying to represent.
This is a better
basis to represent
a jump, a discontinuity,
than Fourier.
Because Fourier, at a
discontinuity, does its best
but it's not a local basis.
It can't, like, especially
focus on that jump point.
And and the result is the
coefficients decay very slowly
and it's hard to compute with.
Whereas the wavelet is great
for signals that have jumps.
If something happens
suddenly at a certain time.
Anyway, that would be
another, and of course I
haven't made these
unit vectors, I'd
have to divide that by
the square root of four
and divide these guys by
the square root of two just
to normalize them.
But normalizing isn't important.
Orthogonal is what is important.
OK, so that's competition,
you could say.
That's the competition.
OK, back to main guy, so this
is the famous formula that gives
the y's from the c's, and what's
the other formula that gives
the c's from the y's?
So now this is the transform
in the other direction.
So it's going to be a
sum from j=0 to N-1.
And what's going to go in there?
Have you got the idea
of the two transforms?
In one direction this is e^i--
You see why we don't want
to write it.
That is, that number is
e to the 2pi*i*j*k/N.
That's what that number
is, in the Fourier matrix.
So you see using w
makes it much cleaner.
OK, what goes there? w bar.
The complex conjugate, e to
the minus all that stuff.
w bar to the same power, jk.
And then I have to remember
to divide by N somewhere.
I can put it here, or
I can put it there.
But the all ones vector has
length squared equal to N
and I've got to divide
by an N somewhere.
OK, those are the two
formulas that many people
would just remember.
For them that's the
discrete Fourier transform
and the inverse, and maybe they
would put the N over there.
Probably that would
be more common.
I got started with the Fourier
matrix, with this side,
and then the DFT matrix comes
here, and I needed the N.
So those are the formulas.
I don't know how you'd
prefer to remember these.
Somehow you have to commit
something to memory here,
certainly what w is.
And the fact that
it's w and w bar?
And the fact that the
sums start at zero.
And the fact that you have
just these simple expressions
for the entries in the matrix.
And this then would be
c equals F inverse y.
That's what I've written
down there in detail.
OK, so that's the discrete
Fourier transform,
and I think we're out of time.
I've got more to say in a
little bit about the FFT,
how that works.